free college tuition universal health
care endless social services if Bernie
Sanders becomes president what it really
pull it off hi Bernie fans you're gonna
want to watch this whole video before
commenting for starters when Obama was
elected remember that warm welcome our
top political priority over the next two
years should be to deny President Obama
a second term Bernie Sanders known once
as the socialist mayor of Burlington
would obviously face the same resistance
on day one as president
it's called GOP obstructionism and it's
our political reality so for Sanders to
do basically any of his platform
promises he'll meet congressional
support no no and he'll need a lot of it
after all the Affordable Care Act passed
thanks in large part to a Democratic
majority in the House and a super
majority in the Senate but even with
that supermajority super progressive
measures like a public option still got
no traction now let's get hypothetical
let's say come January 2017
president Sanders has a super
progressive supermajority in Congress
and is able to pass a super free college
tuition according to his plan two-thirds
of the price tag would come from taxes
on Wall Street but there's a snag states
would have to kick in the final third
and while some states might be down to
chip in expect major resistance for
states led by Republicans because
remember when the Affordable Care Act
passed 22 states through huge Tantrums
about paying for the Medicaid expansion
even though the federal government said
well guys chill we're like taking care
of almost all of it but then the Supreme
Court responded a forcing those states
to participate is on Constitution to
ition hello uphill climb Bernie fans I
know we're gonna say just let me get
there
under Sanders presidency pretty much
every American would see a tax increase
which supporters say ends up saving us
in the long run because of all the
social services that we'd receive but
try telling that to any Republican
legislature many of them are so anti new
tax it'll make your eyes roll into
oblivion some weirdly influential
weirdly named tax
even makes elected official sign a
pledge to never raise taxes and a lot of
them have signed it still with me
almost done let me finish this thought
and then you control me to your heart's
content and yes leadership is about
bringing everyone to compromise but how
is that worked out for Sanders well as a
senator he has a pretty bad track record
of writing bills that get bipartisan
support but he is really good at
inserting progressive amendments into
bills but being an amendment warrior
alone isn't necessarily enough to break
up banks or n Citizens United the bottom
line is that Bernie needs more
progressives like him in all levels of
office he's not wrong he needs a
revolution because of president Sanders
alone won't change a thing
okay let me hear it